you wanna do you want to come on an
episode of why school yeah yeah wow we
have so many applicants here what school
what why school oh yeah we do um it's
just like wife classes basically so
things that we're basically training
pool we would train that Pearl to be
wifey material she's getting there and
he didn't think I was wife
but now she decides that she wants
everybody else to come in because I
think she's feeling a bit um overwhelmed
of
its company
bread well okay yeah the bread what did
you have to change everything what have
you had to change since white school
um okay we have we have different
chapters okay this chapter I'm in is
cooking okay so I'm really trying to be
able to cook healthy food for a family
so
um I've been feeding my staff
are they happy about that they're
welcome he's good
look yeah in the beginning I had some
mess-ups I won't lie but I've actually
improved a lot in the last like month or
two well if you can cook can I just
answer the question yeah can I ask
everybody what's their um their favorite
meal to cook what meal if you had 15
minutes to cook
15 minutes one five one five fifteen
what would you cook off the top of your
head what kind of pasta and what oh
about Bolognese okay what would you cook
sort of like chicken pasta with some
cream cheese something like that okay
what would you cook young lady just 15
minutes yeah oh my partner likes corn
beef fashion beetroot so it's pretty
easy okay 10 minutes literally
steak and eggs okay steak in 15 minutes
you could cook my steak you have yours
no it's if you have a blue it's even
nice right I like it I do like it blue I
do like it blue sometimes I like mine
pink so what would you call young lady
um oh sorry I'd probably make fried rice
in 15 minutes that's probably what I can
make with a bit of chicken in it
vegetables peace
okay I would do okay I'm turning I
either want to do the sushi bowl or the
July fries but I just started doing the
jollof rice so I'm like I don't know if
I can get it in 15 minutes 15 minutes
you could cook jollof rice
I'm trying to teach you how to do it TV
you can do it in the rice cooker 15
minutes nothing not the real one I've
done the railway that takes a lot longer
but uh
what is your favorite thing to make
cookies
I have a family like recipe that my
grandma tell my mom my mom taught me and
it's like cookies from scratch I like
that I'm a really big dessert person
it's not good
um but Auntie also just taught me a cake
that I really like making too it's not
so the things that not good for her yeah
oh yeah tell me about it I had to stop
baking when I started losing weight it
was like well I can make a Victoria
sponge or I can lose no weight so it's
gonna be one of the other yeah I've had
the same realization recently yeah when
you get a foot when you get a text at
two o'clock in the morning where are the
cookies there's no sugar in the house
[Laughter]
and then the next episode uh or next
month what are we doing fashion we're
doing fashion yeah and then the month
because I've always been a tomboy so
I've always really like I've just been
such a Tumblr I've just never keep
wearing it just right now I know it's
big for me
because a year ago I was in sweats every
time I should see what you was wearing
that day when I cut your trousers up oh
yeah yeah and he like
um she cut my jeans because yeah because
she felt like they were ugly I'm pretty
lit I'm pretty laid back How's that
gonna go ahead
they're really nice shorts
um and then after that what are we doing
etiquette yeah etiquette
um and then dance and then yeah oh wow
dance as well yeah who's are you
teaching dance no we're probably getting
it
probably get like an instructor or
something
but you have to whine she's been at
dancing already but she won't post it
she went 60s Go-Go dancing oh no I
always I keep pressing it's so close oh
I'm sure you do
I've set her up I've said this to a
dance class when she got there she
realized what it was for yeah I love
that no I didn't know what go go dancing
was it was like a whole Community
they're like obsessed with the 60s yeah
and I was like they're like what do you
love about the 60s I'm like nothing
I guess I guess this clap happens
no they were young actually most people
I would say were like 20s and 30s there
was like only one or two older ladies
wow yeah yeah they're mostly anyone else
taking an owl anyone else in
relationships yeah like a tooth that was
the L I took from the relationship
I remember I meant you were you look
back and you say that you you lost
like you were not the winner you were
the loser
I think I've dumped every man that I've
ever been with and I've always won
I'm glad
yeah
that's good no one else
really wow
so I don't feel like I've lost in a
relationship I mean you're only 19. yeah
yeah but yeah I don't yeah the thing is
I don't have too much to lose right do
you get it like other than emotional
damage
probably like drama probably like daily
routine I don't really have much to lose
compared to other people like money's
not involved in it family's not involved
in it friends barely you know
so to be fair I don't feel like I've
lost in a relationship why do you have a
relationship why do you what is it about
relationship why do you go into
relationship at such a young age
um I think I like having someone there
that I can confide in I don't get a dog
or a teddy bear
[Music]
um I think mostly because
I like someone that can add on to my
lifestyle I like someone that I can at
the end of the day go back and be like
this is like this is my person kind of
like my best friend
um how's it working for you
great
are you in a relationship now
is it's complicated
but
that's still great that means no it's
either yes or no nothing's complicated
or situation [__] so I'm tired of
situation ships complicated no are you
in relationship yes or no okay I am not
in a relationship I am in a I am in a
partnership which we're still figuring
stuff out
um I recently just tried to cut cut him
off
um no
no
um so I think it was more so we kind of
went cool like this is why so maybe it
was a bit of a hasty decision so we can
stay in until we try to figure out
what's up and if it's not meant to be
it's not meant to be but yeah that's a
lot for such a young age
yeah I feel like a lot of younger
generation feel like they need to be in
a relationship
um I've got two girls
um and my youngest feels like she needs
to be in a relationship and I don't I
don't get it but and where my job and
what I I work with children
a lot of young teenagers and adolescents
feel like they need
to be in a relationship it's quite scary
I think I think more so than being in a
relationship I think it's more so that
you don't want to lose that person so
the only way you don't lose someone is
kind of if you kind of go quite
understand that relationship I'm not
saying that's the that applies to me
right now but that's kind of like
well I think the general mindset is can
I give you a bit as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible